chaque jour les enfants arrivent de à la
maison
très heureuse très curieuse très engagée
dans leur apprentissage de français ok
vous pouvez enlever les manteaux
jamais français avec si je le choix je
vais faire la franchise
sa sœur madeleine en a 8 elles sont en
immersion française à l'école
élémentaire de Harvey Fredericton
elles peuvent déjà bien lire et écrire
en français et les parents en sont fiers
ils veulent des enfants bilingins
mais il s'inquiète pour le petit Jacob
il est en maternelle et ne pourra
peut-être jamais faire l'immersion
française au Nouveau-Brunswick
le Premier ministre belings veut
commencer à éliminer l'immersion pour
les élèves de la première année dès
septembre au moment où Jacob doit
entreprendre sa première année
au début c'était incroyable parce que je
n'ai pas voulu le croire incroyable pour
Julian gabrent incroyable aussi pour les
parents assis autour de cette table
ils sont du réseau canadienne
réunit en comité des provinces de
l'Atlantique avec la représentante
nationale ce sont des parents
anglophones qui militent pour
l'apprentissage du français au pays et
ils tiennent à l’immersion française
toujours comme un leader surtout dans la
matière des langues officielles
l'apprentissage la recherche de
nombreuses recherches démontrent que
l'immersion française forme les élèves
les plus bilingues
alors pourquoi le premier ministre
blending est-il pressé d'éliminer
l'immersion française
notre but est d'avoir plus d'enfants
anglophones capable de s'exprimer dans
les deux langues expliquent-ils et non
plus seulement ceux de l'immersion qui
représente environ le tiers de tous les
élèves oui quel programme pour tous va
donc remplacer l'immersion française les
familles ne savent toujours pas à 10
mois de la prochaine rentrée scolaire
je suis très frustrée nous explique
Natacha parce que je perds mon français
elle fréquente l'école mais pour Hearts
à Moncton où on a implanté un projet
pilote les élèves d'immersion de
septième année comme elle se retrouve
dans les classes sous les enseignants
donnent le cours à la fois en français
et en anglais ce n'est donc plus de
si on parle de moins en moins en
français on le perd ajoute-t-elle c'est
pour ça que je vous parle en anglais
sa mère est très déçue il se demande
comment Natacha va réussir à rattraper
le français qui l'a déjà perdu cette
année elle se demande aussi ce qui
attend tous les autres élèves de la
province une fois l'immersion abolie
partout
ce irresponsable de vouloir remplacer
l'immersion aussi vite et sans un plan
solide ditel qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait aujourd'hui
inquiète elle ne peut qu'espérer que le
nouveau programme de septembre sera
aussi efficace parce que sinon pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a enlevé cette opportunité
parce que c'est que c'est très populaire
dans notre province je pense que j'ai
besoin de faire